los cielos de la ciudad más poblada de
Canadá están cubiertos de neblina a
Toronto en el este del país llegó el
humo producido por los incendios
forestales de provincias del extremo
oeste como Alberta y Columbia británica
salgo a caminar todos los días por la
mañana y me doy cuenta que la calidad
del aire ha empeorado a 400 kilómetros
en la capital canadiense otawa el humo
también ha limitado algunas actividades
en el exterior el servicio meteorológico
nacional ubicó a la capital en la peor
clasificación de su escala de calidad
del Aire El Primer Ministro canadiense
Justin trudeo informó a la prensa que el
país enfrenta a una de las peores
temporadas de incendios forestales de la
historia desde mayo los incendios han
arrasado más de 3 millones de hectáreas
en casi todas las 13 provincias y
territorios de Canadá de Costa a costa
del fuego avanza Quebec es la víctima
más reciente con cerca de 140 incendios
activos en esta provincia
han tenido que ser evacuados mientras
bomberos canadienses y de varias
nacionalidades combaten las llamas
hay 414 incendios forestales Ardiendo
239 de los cuales están fuera de control
también a la fecha estimamos que veinte
mil ciento ochenta y tres personas
siguen evacuadas de sus hogares Y
comunidades
la situación podría empeorar en las
próximas semanas con el inicio del
fenómeno del niño los incendios causados
por altas temperaturas son el rostro el
cambio climático en el país
norteamericano